- [Mark] All right, Octavio.
Octavio, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from?
- I grew up around the
San Fernando Valley.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family.
You had both your parents growing up?
- [Octavio] Yes, I did, yes I did.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- Interesting.
I was like the black sheep of the family
and I used to get in
trouble a lot from parents.
They were strict,
they were real strict and
my brothers and sisters,
they were kind of like goody two-shoes
and I was opposite.
I was always in trouble around gangs.
I got in a gang at 12 years old.
- [Mark] 12?
- Yeah.
- Started one of the gangs.
We started a clique around my neighborhood
and still today it's up and going.
- [Mark] And you're still active today?
- Yes, I am, very active.
- [Mark] Tell me about
your first gang experience.
- My first gang experience
is just, basically,
just hanging out with my new brothers.
They became my family,
you know what I mean?
And just growing up with them
it was like,
it was different from
growing up with my brothers
'cause my brothers were, like I said,
goody two-shoes and they were always
real snotty, you know what I mean?
Good grades and whatever,
and I was the opposite.
I mean, I haven't done anything wrong.
I got good grades, I attended school
and I did what I had to do,
but for me, I used to go to school
just to be with my homeboys,
keep my homeboys and the
homegirls and hang around.
And then we got,
the first of all was just getting together
and just hanging out,
you know what I mean?
Drinking, drugs wasn't even
really a problem back then.
It was smoke a little weed, drink,
and then we started using
PCP and other drugs.
Not really abusing them, but just,
the weekends go use them and drink, party,
shoot up, hang and do
whatever you got to do,
to survive out there.
We used to hang around a
liquor store in my hood,
the parks, and there'd
be maybe like 50, 60
of us hanging at the park.
Yeah, and then people,
our enemies would come.
We have, within my neighborhood
we'd have to drive through,
it was a cruise spot,
so there was neighborhoods
from all over coming
to my neighborhood and we'd
get into it with all of them
'cause it was our hood,
so we didn't let no one come in.
You know what I mean?
They came in, we're on them.
And they come up in my hood,
it was like, they were
getting the bad end of it
'cause it was our hood.
We knew the escapes and how to get to them
and how to block 'em in 'cause
it was a drive-through mall
and one car is this and go come this way,
so you're gonna come
one way in, one way out.
And we'd get 'em in the mall
and they'd be in trouble.
And they'd come and tell ya another thing
and we'd be going back and forth
and we'd be killing each other.
I think '84 and '85 I
lost about nine homeboys
and it was a bad year for us.
Right now I'm 54 years old
and I survived over there,
but I guess God has another
plan for me in life.
Right now I strive to be a
productive member of society
and I wanna do good.
I'm trying, I'm struggling,
and it's just hard for me right now.
And I've tried programs.
My addiction is what's
keeping me down now.
It ain't about...
I come out of jail or prison, I've been,
I did 25 years in prison.
That's just CDC, California
Department of Corrections,
I already did that.
And I come out of jail and
I know nothing but prison,
I know nothing but the
life I lived before.
And for me, for using drugs, it's not...
It's my downfall, yeah,
but more my downfall now, my old behavior,
because once I go be like my old behavior,
it's like everything falls in place.
You got drugs, women, and
whatever else you got,
you know what I mean?
And gang life, surviving the gang life.
Still today, like I said,
I'm still doing any old shit,
doing what I'm not supposed to be doing.
You know what I mean?
And I'm getting away with it.
Like I said, I wanna be a
productive member of society.
And my time will come.
Right now I'm working on a few things,
I wanna start gang intervention
for the youngsters,
I wanna do that for them.
I wanna give back something
that wasn't given to me,
give something that wasn't given to me.
You know what I mean?
And for the youngsters to give
themselves a chance in life,
'cause right when growing up,
you only know one way and that's the way
that we can use our environment,
the people we run with, the people,
what we see on the street coming
out our front door.
It's like gang life.
So right away, you already
don't have a choice.
I mean, you do have a choice,
but you don't make the right choice
'cause you always go the wrong way.
My thing is this, if you're under 18,
you're not supposed to make
decisions on your own anyways,
but you do, but you
shouldn't make that decision
to be in a gang first,
you know what I mean?
Say once you're 18 years
old and graduate high school
and you decide you wanna go to the gang,
then that's to go that route.
But if you graduate from high school,
you're not gonna go the gang life.
You're gonna do good.
'Cause most of the gang members
don't graduate high school.
But you end up getting your GED in prison
because my education was in prison.
I took plumbing, got my GED,
and then I took an apprentice prep program
at Pasadena City College and I graduated.
And I got a union job, but like I said,
right now my addiction is,
my addiction bring it down.
- [Mark] Is it the drug
that's your biggest problem,
or is it the gang life?
- It's the drugs right now.
It's drugs, yeah, I'm
struggling right now.
- [Mark] What's your drug? Heroine?
- I don't wanna say, but
yeah, pretty much, yeah.
- [Mark] A lot of the gang
members find heroine too.
- It's heroine, it's heroine.
- [Mark] Especially in these panic ones.
- I struggle, like I said, I'm struggling.
The corps send me to programs
and I end up fucking them up
and I want a chance,
eh, I wanna give my...
It's hard for me right now, man.
I'm really struggling, dude.
It's hard, real hard.
- [Mark] What was the prison time for?
- Prison time for different things.
Just like assaults,
firearms,
possession for sales, sales of narcotics,
just things like that.
Car jacking, I car jacked.
I got seven years for a
carjack I didn't even do,
but I'm not gonna snitch on my homeboy
so I took the rap and I got
seven years for it, yeah.
Shit like that, you know, just.
I caught a case in prison, jail.
Like I said, I'm struggling man.
I really wanna go the right way,
but it's hard for me,
it's really hard for me right now.
- [Mark] Do you have kids?
- It's gonna come.
Yes, I do.
I have a lovely daughter
that I love very much,
and I can't say I wanna do it for her
'cause it gotta be done for myself.
I'm at that point that I'm
desperate to get right,
you know what I mean?
I'm really am, you know, it's like,
I wanna do the right thing.
I wanna be, like I said,
a productive member of society.
That's what I wanna do.
You know what I mean?
- [Mark] Were you in your daughter's life?
- Nah, I just call her.
I'm not in her life really at all,
just by phone calls and I haven't seen her
in like three years.
That's a long time.
And I call up my mom.
I don't see her either, but
I talk to them on the phone,
but maybe once a month if I'm not in jail.
Even in jail, I try to
call them once in awhile.
But relationship, I don't
have with them at all
as far as what I want to.
What I would like to,
I would like to be in
in their life completely but I'm not.
- [Mark] So the fact that
you're siblings walked
a very straight path and
yours was very different,
what do you think set you on this path?
Was it just the way your brain is wired?
- I don't know.
It's not even the drug no more, it's not.
It's not, it's miserable.
I'm miserable right now,
you know what I mean?
I don't know what it's gonna take,
I don't know what it's gonna take
for me to get right.
I'm trying, I want it, I
want it, I want it so bad.
It's like, man, I just need the help
and the program's not helping me.
It's like, no one's hitting me-
- [Mark] Have you been through rehabs?
- In the head with a hammer
and knock it in so I
could do the right thing.
I don't know, I don't
know what I could do.
- [Mark] Have you tried
rehabs and stuff like that?
- I've tried rehabs, and I get,
I wanna go, I wanna try rehab again.
I do wanna go to rehab.
It's a start, you know what I mean?
To go in the right direction,
but I came out of jail and recently,
a month and a half ago and
I wanna go to a program
'cause that way I can come
into society little by little.
Do the program and then go to outpatient,
you know, stuff like that and sober living
and just try to do the right thing,
but it's difficult right
now to get into a program
'cause coronavirus has a
lowered down the intake
for the program.
- [Mark] What is your biggest regret?
- Right now my biggest regret is, hmm,
I have a lot of regrets, lot of regrets.
Man, I mean, my regrets are just,
I guess, joining the gang.
It really brought me to
this lifestyle I'm in now,
you know what I mean?
Led me there.
- [Mark] What kind of,
tell me the craziest stories you got
from your gang, gang life?
- Craziest stories in the gang, in prison
or out of prison?
I've seen a lot of things.
I got post-traumatic stress disorder
from things I've seen in
prison and on the street.
- [Mark] Oh, is that right?
- I just about died, dude died in my arms.
- [Mark] So prison is just
as violent as outside?
- It can be.
It is, it's like a lot of
things happen in prison
that you'd be amazed,
you know what I mean?
Like wow, you know what I mean?
People getting stabbed.
I got stabbed in a riot with
against the northern Mexicans.
Which northerners, they
call them Nortenos,
we don't get along with them.
We got in the yard, we
had a program together.
We started beefing with each other
and a riot kicks off and people
getting stabbed and hurt.
We're the same race, we're the same
and it's like, what the hell?
But nowadays it's not like that no more.
Everybody gets along.
I mean, I get along, we program together
and we have that respect,
that mutual respect that
there's nothing going on
in the yards right now, the prison yards.
- [Mark] What kind of stuff
were you involved in outside?
- As far, outside?
Things get ugly, now it's like, you know.
- [Mark] You can be vague.
I don't want you thinking-
- I don't wanna go too
deep 'cause it's like,
the gang life we live out here is like,
not no more like before.
Before it was a whole different story.
I mean, now it's diluted,
it's like watered down
and it's like people are
already over that, you know?
'Cause we used to be killing each other,
every week we could have a murder.
We'd hear that someone got killed.
Before it was drive-bys
and not it's not even,
you don't even hear
about drive-bys no more.
And there used to be four in Los Angeles.
Every weekend someone got shot.
People are still getting shot,
but for other reasons besides gangs,
you know what I mean?
But it's dangerous out here,
it's still dangerous out here
but it ain't like before,
you know what I mean?
People just doing, I don't know,
I don't wanna elaborate on all that.
But gang life is dangerous.
- [Mark] What would you say to a young man
who's considering?
- Go the opposite way.
Give yourself a chance.
Gang life's not for us,
especially the Hispanic community.
We need, we need to stop being suppressed
and move forward, you know what I mean?
Move forward and,
I know we could do it, eh?
As a community we could do
it and do the right thing.
It's gonna take a lot of work,
but I know we could do it.
I wanna do to the gang
intervention for the kids,
when you go to school and talk to the kids
that it's not the right way.
I'd like to get started
but I have to get some kind
of sponsor and some support
and that will lead me
in the right direction
just to get it started.
I want to start the gang straight,
I mean, Scared Straight.
It was done by LAPD before by Tony Pierce.
He's from (indistinct).
and he started it with LAPD
and it went down, but
I wanna start it again
but not with LAPD but maybe Fluid Center.
You know what I mean?
Get some kind of intervention
so the kids don't come,
the kids don't think that's
the only choice they got
is to go in the gangs, 'cause they don't.
They have other choices they could do
instead of be in a gang.
And like I said, that's
my main downfall is being
in a gang at a young age
and just starting going that route.
It's like, man, I'm 54
years old right now.
It's time, you know what I mean?
Just to kick back, give to the grandkids
what I didn't give to me kids.
My kid, she didn't
deserve the hand she got.
She should've been with
her dad more closely.
She's doing all right, she's over it,
but you know, I still
feel like she could've had
a lot more from me.
And I would like to give
my mom back her son,
my daughter back her dad,
and my brothers back their brother.
Stuff like that, you know what I mean?
I really wanna give it.
They don't have me in
their lives right now
and I would like to be in their lives.
It's hard.
It's a little journey for me
and I'll make it happen.
Eventually, I'll make it happen.
And what got me thinking is,
what's my, what's it called when they?
Eulogy, eulogy, what's it called?
- [Mark] Eulogy.
- Yeah, what's it gonna
look like for my kids,
coming from my daughter,
what's it gonna be?
Oh, Dad died of getting shot.
Or Dad died of a heroine overdose.
You know what I mean?
What's it gonna say about me?
What can she say about me?
What does she know about me?
Does she really know me?
No, she don't know me.
And I want to get to know her
and I want her to know the real me
'cause I am a good person, I just,
I'm surprised by all
the bad things in life
and I wanna change.
I wanna change, it's what I want.
That's all I got.
- [Mark] All right, Octavio,
thank you so much for sharing your story.
- Yeah, thank you.
- [Cameraman] Thanks, man.